you
hi everyone is Jerry I have a chess
miniature to share with you from 1967
this is the game between Bobby Fischer
playing on the white end and Peter Deli
so let's dive in and see what made Team
Black throw in the towel after just 17
moves
efore by Fischer Sicilian on board open
Sicilian what variation classical 96
what follows is an attack developed by
Bobby Fischer and Veniamin sozin if
you're not picturing anything when you
hear Fischer so is an attack let me fill
you in
let me help you out here the Fischer so
is an attack is when White's pieces on
the F file look to influence the weakest
square and blacks camp f7 if you don't
like that description here's another
miss when White's King Bishop tries to
become a beast let's see how Bishop c4
e6 Bishop b3 he's much more secure here
it's out of the way of a rook attack
indwell much more directly d5 punch a6
f4 is not played to control e5 it's to
attack this structure and hopefully
extend the scope of the king bishop
Queen a5 white castle's white gets out
of the pin Knight takes Knight Queen
takes Knight and let's just pause for a
moment 10 moves in
a good move here for black would be to
develop Bishop d7 Bishop e7 I'd be
leaning more towards Bishop e7 bringing
it to a point where you're now one step
away from castling in the game however
black goes astray with d5 now on the
surface it must be said this seems like
a pretty good move because there's a
serious threat connected with it that
threat being Bishop to c5 winning the
Queen
however White has a perfectly convenient
reply to it Bishop III follows this is
something white wanted to do anyhow and
now black all of a sudden is in serious
trouble because the one positive that
came with d5 has now been negated white
was not inconvenienced with Bishop to e3
and so what remains are just all
negatives for black what are these
negatives well d5 is wasting time and
maybe more importantly d5 is welcoming
exchanges at a moment where black is
behind in development d5 is the point of
no return this position will now be
cracked open and fissure is simply
relentless from here Knight takes e4
Knight takes e4
pawn takes Knight and unlike mr. dully
Fisher does not dilly-dally how creative
was that right dilly-dally first time I
got to say that on this channel probably
be the last f5 not wasting any time in
other words taking out efore white is
pushing through with this idea to extend
the scope of the Bishop f5 is in and
black realizing things are getting out
of control and that this position is
soon to be cracked open says can we
please get the Queen's exchanged with
Queen the B form Fischer takes on e6
taking the Queen now would allow pawn
takes pawn and only then the recapture
so have to keep the material it's
already busted at this point but what is
tried is Bishop takes e6
takes bishop pawn takes Bishop and
here's the pop quiz of this game 15
moves in two more moves and black throws
in the towel what does Fischer play next
if you'd like to go ahead pause the
video see if you can find the best
continuation
okay
in the game we had rook takes bishop
the Queen has to recapture otherwise
Queen takes Queen
and now just one more move what is this
exactly how good a move is it well clean
to a four and yeah black throws in the
towel why
well maybe black was only anticipating a
move like Queen takes e4 here throwing a
punch at these two but that could be
defended with Queen to e7
after Queen to a forum what does black
do let's look at the choices for the
king going here no
going here no running somewhere else
with the king like this well that's not
gonna work either he's gonna get hunted
down by all the white pieces crazy pig
on board how you stopping Queen c7 let's
just look at one variation this is
definitely not working
leading to me any other move well there
is one other move and that is to not
move the king b5
however after b5 what would follow is
Queen takes e4 in this move is now that
much more powerful she's no longer
striking at ISA 'kz and b7 but rather
the rook in the corner there is not
Queen a 7 to defend what does this mean
the rook has to move the Queen is able
to invade we know what happens if the
King goes to these two squares Bishop
move or rook move the rock asta block
and the typical piling up on the pinned
piece with Bishop to b6 following will
soon win the rook there's no way to save
the game here for team black the threat
here is Queen c6 and to simply scoop up
the rook next black saw this already at
the point of queen - a form knew what
was going to happen after b5 Queen takes
pawn and basically all three pieces
would be attacking the king and this
rook on the h8 square will not be
contributing at all
so a seventeen mover a quick kill black
wasted time white simply punished team
black for not getting on with
development opening up black trying to
open up the position when he was behind
the development was simply shot right
down anyhow feel free as usual to leave
any feedback to this video in the
comment section below hope you're having
a great thing and I'll catch in the next
video that's all for now take care bye
you